sidemen of rated everyone and I'm here
and I'm not number one on YouTube
generally where would you rate yourself
God tip top to top to number one number
two baby
yes that's what I'm talking about call
my channel Asda pie I don't know why I
just sort of came dozen anyway true news
[Music]
coming up in true news we look at what
the side men have been saying about
where they run me as a YouTube discuss
the fact that logon Paul isn't doing a
London press conference and why and a
dad jumps off the side of a hill with a
child this episode of true news is
sponsored though Brian unbelievably
again thank you very much the guys
response this last month raid shadow
legends William gu when we first picked
it up last month we were like this is a
good RPG this is a mobile game which is
at the level of a PC or a games console
you can play it anywhere Castagna more
boil in bed yeah whatever the best thing
about it is it is free there's lot of
cool champions out there and of course
like I said last time my favorite
champions Gallic prime really really
good champion not only because he's got
good skills he's got good leadership in
the game also just as his animations
look cool they're almost ten million
players worldwide already right and that
downloaded the game in just six months
three incredible there are more than
300,000 reviews on the Play Store make
sure you get your reviews in as well
knows already sent me and don't forget
to give it the top rating because it's
already top rated on the Play Store your
other pretty amazing and I've actually
been playing a little bit since I'm a
bit of a mobile gamer myself so I've got
new awesome rewards package and the
games going super fast so they've done
this sort of cool road map where you can
sort of see where it's all going
they've actually got huge plans for
updates in the next six months so
there's infinite content for you guys to
enjoy and no time to get bored there's a
new facture and the tag team arena and
even a new clan boss and you'll be able
to fight with your clan mates so you can
find me under the nickname loves cars
obviously but that's only if you're
quick enough to join my clan not only
that but if you head to the link in the
description and I've written it down
here because this is such a good offer
if you click on the special links down
there you get 50,000 silver and a free
epic champion as I say we don't care
about you we love lies you player
program go take a look at it it is
genuinely incredible right so I don't
need to look at this yet you want to
watch the start of the videos you want
to go straight to the good stuff do I
want to listen to sidemen banter I think
we all know the answer Allah or as we
call it Santa rongling youtubers is
really like odd isn't it because it
depends on what you're in like I guess
we written talent yeah clearly from the
list and the way the list goes we're not
rating talents alright yeah
views basic we're probably rating we'll
use and also whether they've gone out on
a few nights well whether they've had
some good times if they're how many
video if a sideman butthole they're
gonna be high on this list [__] to me
though if I was going to do my own list
it would be hard because even even it
depends on what you're into personally
so you can't really do it's not like
football we score more goals you're a
better player top sort of [__] you know
what I'm saying now they got into
ranking you think about my dams that's
the thanks you get
for Korean these [__] sports events up
in committee at Nova brilliant oh oh
can we play football barely yeah yeah
make you look good for a [__] whole
two hours yeah will be respond for it no
out of the goodness of my heart and all
sort of cream of the subscribers will we
respectfully commentate about your [__]
goals for a couple of hours oh
absolutely
the only person who's taking you
seriously is it he's the one that you
said was the worst genuinely he's my
favorite here's my here's my favorite
lesson he wanted more bangers banging
podcast [__] that's that's what I do
grown-ups have a conversation and other
people listen to it for more than five
minutes to find it interesting bit
different what used to a crossbow yeah
oh oh did a good dive in Olympics 2012
can't wait for Japan 2020 to come out we
entertain people over the age of 18 who
actually over the age of oh yeah you're
speaking of sex our audience has done
that yeah so [__] you [__] the first
time you wanted to be below zero bacon
oh right hey can I just say yes I'm
taking the piss out of me yeah for
potentially wanting dick yeah so if you
are gay finds more than down for it but
it only theoretical if you argue and
you're a fan of the sidemen just know
that they think it's bloody hilarious
that you'll have a [__] up your ass yeah
they've just had a good laugh at that or
put you know me
personally I think that so you know what
I think you care on the podcast yeah
very very well this is completely
alright then cause you did the David
Icke one we've done Sean outwards I mean
maybe maybe people would like us more
and more crazy golf I put them higher
yeah I mean but must be nice to be able
to do twenty videos in a day and just
have yet are just regular churn up a
factory of [__] I'm not sure they've got
a booger podcast yes and actually take
time and effort into my work because
it's hard actually make this probably
because you can't turn out like dog [__]
why did you keep making [__] true
news because it's easier than a podcast
[__] idiots
bangs use you [__] idiots what you
think we enjoy making true news watching
other youtubers and reacting to it you
think this is all destroyed it's the
worst this is why if I have so much
respect for anyone youtube is well any
he manages to watch other dog [__] and
go Oh funny than that and I like a good
one will at least he makes it
entertaining let's look at who they
rated me equal pattern yeah solid solid
solid Alfie deyes you with the rest of
the Tories and then Jack Mikasa Polly
Polly hasn't made a good video in about
the deck that's not sure he dyed his
hair a few weeks ago his girlfriend that
was actually a really good video wow
yeah wonderful so that's the same as me
going through that every conspiracy
theory in the book with David I
brilliant well done well done Simon
well I melted I think it's probably is
nothing more than a face for some
[__] influencer agency Wow he's the
six nine of that the real gangsters are
in the back the real businessmen are on
the back will make us buy the face of it
though are you saying that influencer
agency is run by gangsters well no but
I'm just saying if they want to if they
want to prove that they're really good
at getting brand deals get this guy a
brand deal look at the dams alright
these deals come on them yeah have
yourself the one saving grace throughout
this [__] list is that they also got
Jack Mira and nice gate cuz to me when
they'd skip makes great videos
me is is top 5 funniest guys on YouTube
in my opinion where the [__] they do
underrated me and Jack I like that
because it's like yeah didn't want to be
in the top 5 anyway yeah didn't want to
be there start out the sidemen rated me
and also done me dirty with the old with
the jokes
do you think really hurtful yeah you
feel it in there thought we had
something
I thought you know and for them to take
the piss out of people who like dicks up
their ass not on not funny is it not
funny you want to go and see what some
of the side men have been doing yeah
let's have a look at their great videos
looking for same quality content oh I do
love it when they take the time to frame
up properly that's that's a bummer
that's god tear your heads cut off in
the video and in it and the screens
shrunken just randomly to the side of
the no reason for it we are continue
where we left off yesterday when we were
rudely interrupted by the beep boop beep
beep fire alarm meat meat how many
seconds were 24 seconds into this before
his weird was complete such a week if
anything I think he he's a user recess
in mid yeah time to reset big star
remotely the operator inside Vic's head
hit ctrl Alt + delete we were on the
verge of working out like a sustainable
way of keeping this big pop up pick up a
picnic isn't that the no and I called my
Divya ironically full circle big Papa
pickups 10k calories challenge I'll
explain more in a bit I need to have a
huge breakfast to catch up which means
we go pepperoni passion some of these
videos or why we struggle in meetings
when people go oh you're on YouTube this
is why youtubers have got a bad name
basis yeah the weird thing is mini mince
is making a video of something that you
do on a daily basis literally like oh
10,000 coloring challenge Brian's like
it's not a thing exactly and a Thursday
well by day oh that's gonna be right
okay that's not corn the gym let's show
you how it's done this is well you be a
man yeah exactly yeah ten thousand
calorie comrades just let me put this
nobody should be in dominoes midday
especially when they woke up 29 minutes
ago that's just wild yeah you are a
loose cannon where's it gonna stop Wow I
don't I mean this guy's likes coffee
yeah he's sitting there with a pile of
pepperoni you know Lynn start we're all
done sir they're all waking up one of
them goes [__] out he's doing this
great thing where he wakes up yeah I
should wake up you know the side bit
mrs. Vick stars currently the best
content so yeah I made a whole minute
through that Billy yeah that's a long
minutes on bad wake up I'm gonna go wake
up Charlie you know you Charlie I wake
up a pile of cocaine ironic nobody it
wakes him up for a man who laughs a lot
bazinga not very funny not a comedian is
he I don't see him having a stand-up
comedy - I mean I actually love it what
he just throws a glass of water to the
crowd wake up who's the other side Matt
what other ones Toby just opening this
advice changed my life he wouldn't like
anything up his ass would it no we're
not or is he one of those closet Christy
don't go into those make the job or not
really secretly they're like yeah but I
kinda like that too
no just a book plug something right
that's how it starts yeah if it starts
with a butt plug
well well usually it starts with the
last sort of room in you have you ever
had been rimmed before Toby let us know
in the comments lissa imagine if in this
video the advice that change his life
was try [__] yeah I think so that was
a Seidman I mean you want to see I've
gotta be honest right yeah I expected it
from the other [__] but if I said
something it would break my [__] hot
yeah he's my favorite yeah observer went
what that little [__] gay beau who
one who loves shoving stuff up his ass
yeah that would really have ups that
would have really hurt me yeah me as
well actually the kitchen you only if
thought it happened I'd be on the way
over in Anubha right now yeah in a new
Bow Wow threatening there is no press
conference in London for ksi and Logan
Paul yeah a lot of people think that
that start the log and bottling the
London press conference could there's
all just don't give a [__] about London
just own up hand for it they're not
looking to get a English audience out
with this so they like yeah what's the
point we're not going in that Tim zone
they said yeah so which was fine I don't
blame them they're the ones shelling out
all the cash
however the hype that we gain from the
London press conference last time was
way more than the American one and it
was way about her
even when Logan just walked off as much
as that seemed bad at the time it was
brilliant it was for the drama it was
brilliant they should have done one I
think it's a mistake and people think
I'm actually complaining because I've
missed out on a page I don't get paid
finding him pay for a game I don't get
paid for any of that he's not business
savvy I just don't think it would be
good for them to not do it but they're
not doing it for that reason and it's a
shame Lawrence yeah SH am a shame this
is a video from the 1980s made about
what people in Sunderland think of gay
people like God has aspired some
people's reactions to the idea of
homosexuality because many people find
it difficult to accept anything not
regarded as normal yeah I mean to date
of the sidemen heretofore the side metal
on a sutherland fork a long time that
really sounds of it my dad told it about
told me about it and then popped your
[__] up me ass well people want to put
up their ass as their decision and that
was the nineteen eighties of sunland
exact last forward 29 years lawrence
what a progressive society on youtube
people just don't seem to feel the same
way now if any gay haters things have
gone wrong yeah a new true but not in
the wrong hall maybe halls fine when are
we were trying to name the kickoff Brian
also suggested any holes a goal that's
it work that's that's not gonna be on
brand yeah
I mean to say I feel it's disgusting man
maybe because grandmother there I don't
find any fault with it but it is
disgusting yeah it's the best thing is
she even goes I don't find any fault
with it I mean it's disgusting myself
but just record not gain never happy
never will be yeah yeah yeah alright not
gay never thought about a cockapoo sauce
yeah that wasn't too bad actually
people of Sunderland actually seemed
pretty yeah it's a lot it's not more
progressive than what I've had recently
if there's one thing that the whole damn
thing taught me yeah was people who are
gay have so much courage and coming out
like no because even just the jokes I
got which would like obviously people
know I'm not gay but the amount of gay
jokes I got in that that were public but
even if you had have been gay or
bisexual which or not but if you had of
you it would have changed you wanted to
come out so yeah oh yeah definitely I
thought myself [__] hell if I was gay
bloody hell I'd be up what would you do
I'd have a rope around my neck right now
yeah you'll be terrible because I'm the
amount of abuse that was like homophobic
yeah people were using I didn't realize
how much homophobia still exists people
using your potential sexuality as a
weapon against 100 ever be that and that
brings one to one other thing I want
cover hmm did you see the kid who made a
joke about Vidal it's very rare get
actually hungry watching YouTube like
even when people have enough for me I
was never like triggered trigger like
I've spent hours with Vidal like he's
one of the best human beings I've met on
YouTube have never liked have met such a
nice guy there's no way edgy joke they
saw or anything like there's no way of
covering that or that is actual racial
abuse like 100% my response to being
cancelled so he's done I want to see
what
hello how are you yeah no I'm all right
it's been a bit of interesting evening
for bit in short I'm not a racist
oh that concludes it then Thank You Brad
I'm done watching arrow news also you
know not racist now judging from all the
cloud emojis on Instagram and YouTube
and everywhere else I've been cancelled
I can't kind of base something before
you can actually be canceled this guy
was never really liked yeah I've never
seen one of his video of the forces so
for instance if I'm thinking of buying
something on Instagram but I don't hit
by I don't need to cancel it exactly
because I never made the order you do
you know what I mean I still stand by
the fact that what I said was a joke I
still stand by the fact that the video
was a joke video that was all it was
intended to be if you're gonna be a
jokester then you actually have to make
clever edgy jokes like there is nothing
funny at all about what you've just
[__] said yeah if you were not even
remotely funny some of his fans tweeted
me more like you know this guy comes
sometimes is funny like you know and try
to sort of explain it this racist
sometimes it's funny and maybe he is
Jeremy but like get a [__] grip your
soul mate like yeah you know when you've
been racist you know the best thing to
do I was a little bit racist and I
didn't think my joke through like I love
the kid right actually really really
care about Vidal and he's taught me a
lot he's been a great friend to me and
to know that he had to watch that and
know that someone was having a Gordon
father [__] skin colour on his body I
genuinely felt like got it in my naivety
I just thought we were actually past
this sort of [__] yeah children I
mean I want to shock people I want to
entertain people and I want to do that
by making jokes like you never really
see people making anymore for good
reason new teeth I want to be a
politician in this country and I want to
be able to do it in the way that they
did in Germany in the 1940s of nostalgic
about it in a way don't see in the world
of the organ Paul Hitler did it
different yeah I mean yeah Hitler on
that our that was Mother's yeah what you
don't see anymore is the policies of the
Nazi Party around all fingers but I want
to bring it back in a way because it
sort it tickled me I'll tell you that
anyway back to my phone Agee Alex just
want to end this one on this guy's
probably not a bad person he's probably
not a racist
despite the heck he just makes
[__] jokes yeah and congratulations the
one time you've gone viral when we were
young there wasn't Kim Kardashian who
was known for sleeping with other
celebrities who was talentless there was
Katie Price she was sort of like a sheet
or TV version of her it was in the days
when plastic surgery wasn't as good just
like to say thank you everybody
who've got switched on and looked at my
youtube channel guys can we get it
switched on please and just look at her
YouTube channel
okay POTUS she's a cautionary tale isn't
you absolutely Yeah right there's a
point where you're at your peak of fame
and looks and all that and there's a way
to maintain that but sometimes you can
keep scrounging for more and end up with
less than what you had and I feel like
that's where she is like her plastic
surgery just went too far her spending
went to it like apparently she's had
money troubles and all women used to buy
her boots buy the [__] bucket Lord
because she was basically telling
everyone like what everyone was like in
bed and all of that [__] yeah I feel
sorry for her cause her face has been
pulled so far back by this facelift
growing old gracefully is a thing isn't
it absolutely why not we've nailed it
let it go she's literally got a shot
that's a mug to be found mean it is the
women's section isn't it if you were
there you'd have gone I love it I'll
help you okay a man in the background
that you just don't [__] hell he's
just it's clearly a dad that's not a
mile it's a woman it really does look
like a mud 10 inches you'd never think
it would you Charlie's got ten in check
come on over Charlie insight of what
really happens in my life I do my
reality show which is good but I'm also
gonna show aspects they don't show so
the reality show which shows every
aspect of your life it doesn't show
every aspect of your life but here's we
get the real [__] guys you already know
everything about me
here's all the stuff you didn't think he
wanted to know about my she's on the
toilet hover this [__] and the cover
just posited it hits the pan and she
goes that's the real [__] not what we
don't show you on the reality show I
think you know life is turning done so
I'm gonna get the whisk to get that one
to go down I feel a bit sorry for her I
feel sorry for her because she was just
a young kid who got caught up in the
fame she went down a road I don't think
she really understood the price of fame
until it was too late in her life it
couldn't be an easy being her throughout
her life so I do I know we've taken the
piss a bit naturally but I do feel a bit
sorry for her I wouldn't want everyone
to be able to see you've had this
problem a few times before in YouTube
videos I won't see my nipples yeah the
price of having great tits this this is
really [__] triggered me right we
joke a lot this is actually like
seriously stupid in my opinion this
guy's being killed by terrorists I'm a
member of the Bloods here so this is the
the diet of the husband or whatever the
[__] he's all harnessed in know it
doesn't look from what I can see at all
from what most of the internet can see
by the looks of it there's anything
keeping her this little baby a touch to
that dad other than his hands as far as
I can see yeah but surely you wouldn't
do that as a parent
honestly honestly all is for that jolt
or your arm anything to go wrong and her
[__] skull is smashing off those
rocks know when I first watched it
because I wasn't sure what I was about
to see and I was like yeah what yeah
like that's some crazy
that is literally risking life for no
reason this turtle was caught just off
the coast of the u.s. trapped in lots of
cocaine this cocaine was around the
turtle and he was obviously trapped but
the police found him and let him go free
I broke the cup the core Kuhn though
this one thing about it is I think this
turtle was literally like suck the [__]
in free funny thing is right
I think this turtle was like I'm almost
at the coastline I think I'm gonna make
it yeah I'm trapped in all this cocaine
ah no yet you've rescued me
what's the cork me no that's not my oh
thanks officer I was just looking after
it for me me no I don't even have any
friends who were drug dealers what see
yeah yeah Jax Curtin Goodman [__] jack
is getting an amazing shape especially
for Chuck because he's never been that
guy in that he's always been he's always
been so thick you know I mean but he's
never been like you know [__] shotgun
yeah I just created it credit rates do
is his chest looks in great I mean look
at that and yeah I'm the one who gets
the homoeroticism jobs I mean it's been
working on it saw the done thing though
those and yeah well do all the youtubers
to do with it I mean we miniman de yeah
yeah exactly
ten thousand calories I read I mean just
a skinny fat scat
Oh hopefully you've enjoyed this episode
of true news let's just run through what
we've heard today the sidemen love like
behind your back hand in front of your
face they rate you as a mid-level
youtuber people on youtuber pretty
racists nowadays in a great episode
though thanks a lot for rate shadow
legends for sponsoring us this week been
really good in that that was the one
positive in this episode we actually
well one of us did so overall a great
day cheers everyone thanks for coming
see on the next episode